I'm hip hop Anthony now you know what
I'm saying were you dancing though like
were you
[Music]
like all right all of you guys who
actually have kid actually have kids are
going to like this all right yeah I'll
shut up for this one then so there's
this childcare worker that was
explaining on social media about how she
has been seeing the difference in like
how kids are today and how she thinks
like Tik Tok is totally ruining them so
she lists all these things that she
observes in them and when I guess like
guys like us start to read this it looks
like we kind of did the same stuff but I
don't know I'll let you be the judge
okay so um is she like uh like older and
she's seen like multi-generations of
kids and she how many generations I
think she's kind of like our age our
like AG so she's seen one generation
yeah you too young to be talking about
back in my day yeah you need to be like
50 or
60 we do that here all the time back in
our day let's see if these things are
unique to the social media age or if the
television age kind of had the same
thing cuz I feel like it did um so she's
look she's observing these kids that are
as young as nine that have Tik Tok
accounts which that is like crazy Tik
Tok is kind of wild though yeah that
sounds like that shouldn't be but uh she
points out these problems she sees the
kids body shaming each other is that
something that we had when we were we
fing did that parents body shamed us but
the but the level I'm curious but it
made us better maybe this one's making
them worse maybe the way and the tack
that they're doing it is not as good
yeah that's true I think I think it
could be the way it's done and yesterday
I just witnessed Tao being
self-conscious for the first time and I
was like oh so like taica love
Spider-Man right that's his favorite
superhero and um so when he first
started Jiu-Jitsu I was like crying
already I was like get I'm gonna get him
a Spider-Man rashgard and you know when
you're a kid you just love everything
that's you know so he has it and and he
loves that [__] Rashard yeah even
though I I love it even more because he
looks [__] [__] in it but it's my
favorite he goes to Jiu-Jitsu yesterday
and he's and he puts on his regular
Spider-Man Rashard a big kid comes in
maybe like 10 or 11 and he's like
Spider-Man Rashard and then he walks by
and ta comes up to me and he goes Papa I
don't want to wear this Rashard I was
like man I was like why I you want me to
[__] that kid up his guard's not that
good
I was like why he goes I didn't like the
way he said it I was like but he didn't
even say it in a bad it was just it was
one of those um just caught him off
guard you know like a grasshopper like
that but then I guess it was just such a
big he's being vulnerable it was just
such a big moment that he was like I
never realized it was going to attract
that kind of attention but also on the
flip side it's one of those things when
the adults watch the kids class all the
adults all the parents like dude I need
a [__] Spider-Man rush too but it
didn't cool an adults say it no I know
and I was like oh [__] so he he has
self-consciousness for the first time
wow so like I haven't experienced you
know like body shaming or whatever at at
like him and his friends level but I
think he's probably going to enter into
that where like now they're like oh look
at your nose look at your eyes look at
your teeth or whatever but I mean in in
a in a maybe different uh positive
environment isn't that like a part of
what makes him mature or stronger you
know what I mean cuz like Tao probably
also is not going to be the type of kid
who wants to wear a Spider-Man rash car
when he's like 14 but the only way to
truly learn or like move past it is when
another Pier you know what I mean kind
of shames you in certain way that's how
we all grew and learned about random
[__] also I take everything with the
Grandin of salt cuz he does have the
memory of like a [__] fly so when
it's Jiu-Jitsu tomorrow he might just
put it on just go straight into it yeah
you know a lot of like a lot of kids
they just like that moment is that
moment so I always have to like see if
it happens three times I don't want to
do it anymore yeah exactly like I hate
this and the [__] him the next week he's
like oh this is pretty good actually I
had u i I have a an older sister so I I
only had hand-me-down type [__] right
and and I was too young to do anything
myself and I remember when she got a CD
player I finally got to take her Walkman
but I didn't know how to [__] do
cassette [__] you know what I mean so I
only had her music on her Walkman but I
just wanted to be cool at school and
have a Walkman right so on her [__]
cassette tape there's like like a virgin
is on there right that's one of the
songs it's just like a mixtape
be I'm listening to my recess cuz I just
want to look cool a [__] kid Jacks it
from me puts it on like let me hear this
[__] here's Like a Virgin blast me in
front of the whole basketball court and
I remember thinking in that moment I
remember thinking that moment from now
on I'm only listening to
rap I'm hi hop Anthony now you know what
I'm saying were you dancing though like
were you
like no not at all I'm just trying to
look cool like can have it on you know
what I mean just like putting it close
to people's
ears but you know what I'm saying like
that's a core memory I'm I'm going to
cry that's crazy there's those moments
that shake you yeah that's [__] crazy
I would have been like getting my best
friend and I'll put like a virgin in the
[__] speaker box so they could be
like like blasting it loud and I'll be
like I'm going to go [__] this
[__] up so you play that really
loud and I just start attacking him so
he could listen to Madonna while I [__]
his ass up every kid wishes they have
that friend you know what the the
inverse of that is there's always that
kid like a that you can't even he's like
bulletproof I remember in high school
there was this one cool ass kid Nam Ryan
and we were all no ain't me we were all
making yeah we were making fun of like
like everybody was like bashy boy is gay
insync is gay like everybody was say
that this one dude like really cool was
just sitting there like like humming the
lyrics and [__] and we were like a
you're gay bro that's insane and he goes
it thing's pretty cool and we're like I
guess I guess this thing is pretty
cool Ryan could do that no dudee you say
I wish I could do that [__] man you got
to get T to do that you got to be like
Spider-Man rest dude I remember it being
in fifth grade and it's a clear memory
because like my hygiene is because of
this guy now I remember in fifth grade I
go over to my homie house he's my best
friend at the time right he lives across
the street I go over there and I don't
know if I was sweaty or whatever and I
was just in his room we're just chilling
and he was showing me this new
turntables he has and he goes bro you
smell like a
dog I remember going like what the [__]
is that even
me from that point on two showers every
day W take my you're very clean shower
before you email take exactly take my
laundry mom you ain't doing my [__]
laundry anymore you put a [__] dog
sents in that's true dog shampoo I need
to do my own [__] laundry just that
one moment that's what I'm saying like
are they talking about girls cuz I know
they go through some completely
different [__] but the thing is like
body shaming I feel like was worse when
we were kids because that [__] was on TV
movies I feel like body shaming affects
girls the most yeah for sure I think the
guy kind of body shaming is different
why uh we're like it's more like you
[__] weak piece of [__] or like you
fat [__] oh like ability no like the way
that that it's like body shamed it's
like it's more like yeah it's more like
um for fun it's not so much yeah I think
the the the way that girls do it to each
other is different oh okay yeah so I
don't know if that's what they're
talking about though like how early the
body shaming comes cuz that's that's how
they grow up with all those [__] up
things about like eating disorders
looking you know like they had that [__]
in our generation too where girls would
be like [__] vomiting food and
they're like trying to be a supermodel
and they're like dude you're in the
fifth grade why the [__] are you
vomiting food when we were kids we
didn't really have the example of like
championing someone for being fat we
didn't have that yeah right like the the
plus-sized models back then are like the
average woman today type yeah we didn't
have that at all and also back then it's
like if you weren't eating there's
plus-sized models back then that's what
I'm saying back then that was who's
going to show the tri XXL vest that
they're selling it it was a plus-size
mon back then wore like mediums but now
it's like they didn't even have them cuz
that's like saying a smart dumb guy
mediumsized model look like like like
Anthony anyways um also back then like
if you didn't eat it was anorex today
they call it like fasting totally fine
with that [__] you know what I mean it's
like everything's just different even
though it's the
same how about this how about um she
said that she'll see people or kids
bullying each other girls were bullying
each other over their parents not being
able to buy them Lululemon that's
[__] oh so that's like a teen thing
that's really the kids they're like nine
and 10 dude lul lemon has a 9-year-old
now yeah now well lul lemon's not the
top dog anymore now it's like normal cuz
L became racist or something that's
[__] like $70 for kid pants yeah dude
inflation inflation we had Miller's
Outpost element pants yeah I was going
to say like that sounds like some Palace
verie struggles you know like kids that
grew up in those neighborhoods even in
the '90s they're [__] making fun of
each other for like not having [__]
that's true it never that always was a
thing yeah so I don't know but being a
baller on social media is I feel like in
everyone's face all the time so it's
like oh you broke it's like it's like
that type of [__] there different levels
like now it's like Bugattis right but
before like when I was a kid like you
don't have airw walks you don't sag your
pants you're lame airw walks with these
sneakers and like before I bought
anything fashionable it was Airwalk was
the first one and I had to beg my
parents to get me a pair cuz I for maybe
they I don't even know how much they
were like 50 bucks maybe or 30 bucks
whatever was expensive back then 30
bucks 35 I had to literally like cried
to get to fit in with the kids cuz they
were getting me like knockoff shoes from
Vietnam shoot my mom's getting me
knockoff shoes from Vietnam now son
you'll love these Nikes Mom they're not
Nikes please stop buying me these things
I'm like they don't look anything like
dks here's here's a unique one um
twerking like little girls are twerking
oh that's s weird I don't know the
equivalent of that from our age I don't
I don't like the sexualization of like
younger people yeah but I think she's
trying to say that because of Tik Tok
that's like algorithmic I think Tik Tok
it fastracks it for sure and it's like
but did we have something like that as
kids I mean no but the freak dancing was
most cuz then like even in fifth grade
that didn't happen for me until High
School freak dance so it's it evolves
sexuality evolves over
time stuff but girls doing it by
themselves just popping it like that's
not that's probably not that good
stripper
[__] probably not that good gold digging
was really frowned upon right and now
it's okay or more okay gold digging like
you'd be like oh you're just saying it
for the money like you're a hoe blah
blah blah and now it's like they're like
promoting us like dude go be a gold
digger get your B go get your thing you
shouldn't pay for a meal you shouldn't
be eating at TGI Fridays or whatever
that restaurant is yeah yeah 2 for 30
the uh 3 what's that restaurant that
everybody's hating on is that expensive
do you yeah which makes me feel like why
it's so good the weirdest thing though
is like why are you hustling for like
$30 that's literally your your meal it's
like 30 [__] it's like 2030 exellent
moment to say buy our merch t-shirts are
on sale right now from the normal $30
price buy it if you don't want to buy it
have some dude buy it for you come on
easy stay warm and careful boy
T